Valérie Gamache.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Inquiétant est plus le mot.
C'est rendu critique.
- Actuellement,
4000 postes vacants à combler
en Abitibi-Témiscamingue.
C'est deux fois plus
qu'il y a cinq ans.
- C'est difficile de recruter
dans des conditions
comme celles-là.
- Garages, restaurants, hôtels,
fournisseurs de services
miniers, résidences pour
personnes âgées, partout la même
enseigne : "Nous embauchons."
JEAN-FRANÇOIS COUILLARD, prés.,
chef de dir. Adria Power Systems
- On peut pas baisser la garde.
T'sais, dans le temps,
on disait : On a besoin de
staff; on va mettre une annonce.
Les annonces, aujourd'hui,
elles sont tout le temps là, là.
- Jean-François Couillard est
président d'Adria Power Systems.
Dans cette usine, on fabrique
de l'équipement destiné
à l'industrie minière.
- Principalement,
c'est des centres
de distribution électrique.
- La demande est là,
mais faute de main-d'oeuvre,
il doit régulièrement
refuser des contrats.
- Quand on est obligé de freiner
les plans de développement
d'une entreprise par manque
de ressources de main-d'oeuvre,
c'est très grave.
- La situation est
particulièrement fragile
en Abitibi. L'indice de
remplacement de la main-d'oeuvre
est parmi les plus bas
au Québec. Alors qu'il s'établit
à 82 % dans la province,
en Abitibi, il est de 69 %,
ce qui signifie que, lorsque
100 travailleurs prennent leur
retraite, il y en a seulement
69 pour les remplacer.
- Présentement, on a deux
soudeurs qui travaillent
avec nous qui sont
sur permis de travail.
- Pour faire face au manque
à gagner, la région
se tourne vers l'immigration.
- On est en train de terminer
un processus pour
cinq travailleurs étrangers.
- Bonjour Claude! Ça va bien?
- Ça va bien! Toi?
- Tu commences ton périple
en France avec quelle ville?
- Bien, je commence avec
Paris, par drôle de hasard.
Mais tout de suite le lendemain,
je me déplace vers Rennes.
- Le Centre local
de développement multiplie
les missions de recrutement
à l'étranger. Cette fois,
on ne vise pas seulement
à attirer des travailleurs
spécialisés, on veut séduire
des familles entières.
MARIÈVE MIGNEAULT, directrice
générale, CLD Rouyn-Noranda
- On recrute les familles
pour que le conjoint aille,
par exemple, aux études et
que la mère vienne travailler
dans les commerces d'ici.
Les enfants, eux, vont à l'école
et, par ailleurs, ce sont
des futurs travailleurs
également. C'est un premier
essai. On se donne deux ans
pour tenter le tout.
Idéalement, dix familles,
ce serait une belle réussite.
- Ce serait aussi une réussite
si ces familles décidaient
de rester au Québec.
- On est situés juste à
proximité de la frontière
de l'Ontario et eux ont
des programmes d'immigration
économique régionalisés.
Ces personnes-là peuvent
venir travailler pour eux
et bénéficier d'une résidence
permanente en trois mois,
comparativement à 3,5 an
pour le Québec.
- Et même après avoir attiré
et retenu des travailleurs
étrangers, la partie n'est pas
encore gagnée pour l'Abitibi.
La pénurie dans les services
essentiels réduit grandement
la capacité d'accueil
de la région.
JOËL GAGNÉ, directeur général
CPE Vallée-des-Loupiots
- On a du béton, on a des murs,
il y a des places. Puis,
on a personne malheureusement
pour pouvoir travailler
à l'intérieur de ces places.
- Le manque d'éducatrices
a forcé ce CPE de Val-d'Or
à fermer ses portes
en août dernier.
- Lorsqu'on a fait notre
portrait de main-d'oeuvre,
on s'est juste rendu compte
que, finalement, on avait
suffisamment d'éducatrices
pour combler les besoins
de seulement deux installations
et non pas de trois
installations.
- Depuis, le service de garde
a pu reprendre en partie
ses activités, mais
l'avenir est incertain.
- Si je vous dis, par exemple,
qu'au Cégep de l'Abitibi-
Témiscamingue, aux dernières
nouvelles, il y avait seulement
huit étudiants en technique
d'éducation à l'enfance.
- Les deux axes, c'est vraiment
CPE, immigration, là.
- Pour sortir du cercle vicieux
de la pénurie, Jean-François
Couillard a décidé de se lancer
dans une nouvelle aventure bien
loin de l'industrie minière.
Il a fondé son propre CPE.
- Il faut s'imaginer
des enfants...
- Le ministère de la Famille
lui a octroyé 44 places,
dont une partie sera
dédiée à ses employés.
- La garderie a été nommée
Explorateurs du monde.
Les enfants, on le sait
que ça va être des enfants
de plusieurs cultures aussi.
Donc, c'est un mélange super
le fun à faire, t'sais, là,
c'est vraiment une continuité
des nos valeurs.
- Un service de garde
qu'il veut à l'image de
l'Abitibi d'aujourd'hui
et, espère-t-il, de demain.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Rouyn-Noranda.